i don't know if i can trust you you
can't you can't but i promise i'll never
betray you again what can i do michael
you can get up
what
get up
and you can hug it out [ __ ]
we have to do something because people
are losing it out there wondering what's
gonna happen
okay we need some sort of distraction
for everybody
michael can i
okay i'm just gonna skip right past the
what and go with why because this is the
recreation of a crime scene i'm the dead
body and these are my brainchild hey
shut up you're dead michael can i talk
to you michael here my caleb
shut up
they need this game jim
let us have this stupid little game all
right
[Music]
what's the news
nothing yet
well i guess that's not well there is
some bad news
there has been another murder
a murderer you say
i do declare
you are a person i do not respect
the things you say your actions your
methods and style everything you would
do i would do it the opposite way
all right you don't respect me
i accept that
but listen to me
you can't talk to me that way in this
office you just can't i am your boss
can't allow it
there enough
hi everybody hey what up
sure glad you're back
you are relieved
you have no idea
so did i miss
well i tried to put all the birthdays
together at once oh so terrible idea
yeah okay i did that
rookie mistake you did do it uh-huh no
just wait ten years you'll figure it out
well i don't think i'll be here in 10
years but
that's what i said
that's what she said
that's what who's that
i never know
i just say it
i say stuff like that you know
to lighten the tension
when things sort of get hard that's what
she said
hey
nice
hey
what's up
same old
it takes a big man
to admit his mistake
and i am that big man
and i apologize
accepted
how's this place treating you
my boss isn't funny
no i don't get to wear my ties no
i'm sure so so maybe you should come
back
you should come back
please
here's the situation your company is
four weeks old i know this business i
know what suppliers are charging i know
you can't be making very much money i
don't know how your prices are so low
but i know it can't keep up that way
i'm sure you're scared
probably in debt that's the best offer
you're gonna get
i'll see your situation and i'll raise
you a situation
your company is losing clients left and
right you have a stockholder meeting
coming up and you're going to have to
explain to them why your most profitable
branch
is bleeding
so they may be looking for a little
change in the cfo so i don't think i
need to wait out dunder mifflin i think
i just have to wait out you
dwight
i will be leaving tomorrow yes so i
wanted to give you that
it's a letter of recommendation
this is gonna be good
to whom it may concern good real
personal thanks michael the dictionary
defines superlative as of the highest
kind quality or order surpassing all
else or others supreme
that's great if i wanted the dictionary
definition
by a dictionary i define it as dwight
fruit
as a sales executive as a leader
as a man
and as a friend
he is of the highest kind quality
and order
supreme
lots more like that really repetitive
this is
245 behind the building paintball
oh
well it's nice for you your friend got
engaged
uh
tell you the truth i
used to have a big thing for pam
so
really you're kidding me
you and pam
wow
i would have never
put you together you really hit it well
god
yeah
she's really funny and
she's warm
and she's just
anyway
unless you like her so much [ __ ] don't
give up
she's engaged
bfd engaged ain't married
never
ever ever give up
pam casso
sorry i'm late i had to race across town
oh michael
wow
you did these free hand
yep oh my god these could be tracings
oh
look at this one
wow
you nailed it
how much
what do you mean
i don't see uh price
um you want to buy it
well yeah yeah we have to have it for
the office
i'm really proud of you
thank you
dwight
i can't be there for you
i'm sorry
jim
i just
really wish there was something i could
do
michael
i can't believe you came
that's what you said
you